Human babies are kind of pathetic.
We can't run from
predators, feed ourselves,
or even lift up our own heads.
But not all newborns are totally helpless.
After all, it's a
treacherous world out there,
and some babies must go
to extremes to survive.
Take barnacle geese.
They lay their eggs 120 meters up
the side of the cliff,
away from predators.
That's the same height
as a 36-story building.
But there's no food for
the chicks to eat up there.
So when they're a few days
old, still incapable of flight,
they leap off the cliff.
Thousands are injured or killed on impact.
But the lightest, fluffiest
chicks survive by floating down
and landing on their soft stomachs.
Baby marine iguanas also have it rough.
They don't have to leap off a cliff,
they just have to outrun
swarms of hungry snakes.
Mothers lay their eggs
in underground burrows
for protection,
but they don't stick around
after laying the eggs.
By the time the babies hatch
up to four months later,
the Galapagos racer snakes
have gathered for a feast.
So the hatchlings have two options.
Stay put and starve or make a run for it.
The snakes are attracted to movement,
so the second the iguanas
take off, snakes give chase,
and only the quickest survive.
While iguana hatchlings
must be fleet of foot,
greater guinea pigs are
speedy in a different way.
Pups can have babies of their own,
just one month after birth.
That's like humans giving
birth at 11 months old.
And unlike other rodents,
the pups are born with
furry coats, open eyes,
and can walk on their first day.
They're pretty much just mini-adults.
Disturbing, right?
Just wait till you hear
about braconid wasps.
Their babies are extreme predators
from the moment they hatch.
Adults hijack a caterpillar
and lay over 100 eggs underneath its skin.
Once hatched, the larvae feed on
the caterpillar's internal organs,
and once it's on the brink of death,
the larvae chew their
way out, spin cocoons,
and emerge as fully formed adults.
Ready to have deadly babies of their own.
Speaking of which, sand tiger sharks eat
their own siblings
before they're even born.
You see, mom has many suitors,
and they all fertilize her
eggs at different times.
So the eggs that are fertilized
early on develop sooner
in the womb before the rest,
and once they're big enough,
they eat their less developed siblings.
And you thought you had annoying siblings.